tum peu du mal un projet était dans les
six mois à venir vivre cette période de
jeunesse là en même temps que c'est que
cette crise sanitaire
ça provoque des angoisses et des
inquiétudes assez particulière nos
projets ils sont mis à plus tard mais on
sait pas quand et puis on va arriver à
avoir zéro vis social au final
mais
on a quinze 15 à 20 appels par jour pour
des demandes de suivi psychologique qui
est nouveau c'est que les étudiants mais
viennent même sur place pour demander un
suivi psychologique et les listes
d'attentes dans tous les centres dans
notre centre et dans tous les centres
comparables sont de plus de 300 400
étudiants on a évidemment des projets on
a des objectifs
on a des rêves nous on n'a aucune idée
de comment les mener à bien sûr ceux sur
ce long terme on est à une période où on
nous demande de penser au long terme
on nous demande de penser au moyen terme
on nous demande de penser aux après
qu'est ce qu'on va faire après les
études ou jusqu'où on va aller dans nos
études est ce qu'on va se réorienter
dans quels domaines on va se spécialiser
est ce qu'on va travailler à côté et où
toutes ces questions là c'est infiniment
angoissant d'y réfléchir sur une période
où tout change d'une semaine à l'autre
ou les règles de vie commune change du
tout au tout d'une semaine à l'autre où
effectivement on est forcé de réfléchir
au temps court
[Musique]
c'est une période où on passe du monde
familial et scolaire à un monde sont
beaucoup plus ouverts sur des choses
nouvelles sur le social et sur des
apprentissages et puis à terme un
travail j'ai énormément de mal à me
concentrer et à ne pas prendre de retard
quand c'est des cours à distance
donc ça rajoute un stress supplémentaire
à une année qui est déjà relativement
stressante de m
la fac déjà pas beaucoup de cadres mais
le cadre a explosé avec toutes les
mesures qui ont été prises dans les
universités la période elle est
particulièrement compliqué pour ceux qui
débarquent à la fac et qui n'ont pas pu
avoir du tout de repères à la fac ni
nouer des relations avec les autres
étudiants donc qui se retrouvent dans
une fac où ils voient les gens une
semaine sur deux masques et l'autre
semaine sur / en visio donc nouer des
liens avec les autres est trop compliqué
être confronté à un cadre encore plus
large que celui de la fac habituelle
quand on sort du lycée c'est très
déstabilisant et puis il ya ceux qui
terminent ce qu'ils sont
alors cette année en master 2 dans les
masters 2 2 qui ont terminé cet été avec
des diplômes qui ont été passées en
ligne sans son rituel sans que les
choses soient incarnés je pense que
c'est très compliqué pour marquer cette
fin des études
et puis bien sûr ils ont leurs angoisses
de ce qui va se passer maintenant pour
trouver du travail pour beaucoup d'entre
eux je dois écrire ma thèse est dans le
vin moi je me vois pas je vois pas ma
thèse écrite dans six mois parce que je
n'arrive pas à m'organiser pour la
travailler et ça pour moi c'est vraiment
c'est ça ce qui m'angoisse
il faut favoriser tout ce qui permet de
rester en lien avec les gens proches qui
compte sur le plan affectif pense que
l'autre chose qui est importante c'est
justement d'essayer d'éviter de se
désorganiser qui se passe à la fac
rend très difficile le fait de trouver
un rythme de trouver des repères et je
pense qu'il faut être très attentif à ce
genre de choses en particulier parce
décalé du point de vue des horaires
essayé de suivre effectivement tous les
cours quand ils sont en distance yale
essayé de suivre le rythme des chauves
qui sont demandés je crois que ça c'est
sait des choses alors j'ai pas vraiment
une petite technique mais c était
quelque chose qui permet de favoriser le
fait d'être en lien avec les autres